Hey guys, how's it going?
>> Hey man,
>> pretty good.
>> All right.
>> Yeah, we're doing pretty good. Pretty
good, man. We got We got one big
question for you.
>> Tell me what's going on.
>> Would you trust a religion with corrupt
description, man?
>> No.
>> Awesome. The Torah, Psalms, Gospel,
>> Quran. These are all books from Allah,
right?
>> One second, man. I'm so sorry. I was
going to say life react, dude. The
lights and the plane combo is dope. I
like that a lot. That's really cool.
>> Oh, appreciate it, man. Thank you. Thank
you.
>> Sorry. Go ahead, man.
>> So, the Torah, Psalms, and Gospel. Um,
these are all revelations from Allah,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Would you say that they got corrupted?
>> Okay. So, what about the Quran? Quran's
all good.
>> I believe it's good. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, three out of the four books of
Allah got corrupted. And so, that means
that Islam is untrustworthy because it
has corrupted scriptures.
>> No, not quite. Um,
>> well, I would say there's a few things
for you to take into consideration,
right? um the message the original
message of Islam um you know it didn't
get corrupted per se right and we had
that maintained for example with uh the
Quran itself right so if we had the
original uh Torah right then that would
still be the valid message of God but
because it got changed by people that's
no longer the Torah so technically the
original copy itself obviously you know
it's still the word of God but since we
don't have anymore it's just a fake
version of it you can't really attribute
the fake version to the original right
>> yeah So within Islam, you have only left
fake versions of these scriptures. You
don't have the real versions anymore.
>> Yeah, but the underlying message was
presented in the Quran.
>> Well, that's cool. That's cool and all,
but you still have a bad track record of
the previous revelations being corrupted
and so therefore Islam is you can't
trust it.
>> No, I wouldn't say so. Um, and the main
reason why I say that is because the you
know, Allah says in the Quran that he's
going to preserve the Quran to make sure
that this doesn't happen again. I think
ultimately people were trusted with this
and I think it's more so like just a
sign of understanding that even when
human beings are given something given
guidance that doesn't mean that they're
necessarily going to stick with it and
they're going to try to corrupt it and
take advantage of it right and so this
time when the revealed you know it was
the last prophet if there was another
prophet coming the prophet would renew
the message
>> right so so it looks like Allah doesn't
really have a good track record of
protecting his scriptures right if he
only protect
>> I would say I would say the way I would
phrase is Allah chose chose not to
protect the scriptures in the past.
>> Yeah. That's like saying that's like
saying a babysitter chose not to babysit
the kids, but on her final job, she
decided to watch those kids, you know?
So, she would have a bad track record as
a babysitter.
>> Yeah. Uh but if the babysitter was all
knowing, I would say it' probably be a
better idea to say, "I trust the
babysitter's judgment." Right. I'm sure
there was a reason why Allahh did that.
Um but of course, I can't tell you
specifically why. I would just say that
the same God that sent the Torah and
sent down the Injil, you know, he makes
these decisions better than we can.
>> Let me So let me let me add to that
then. Do you think that it would make
sense for example, right? Because you're
you're blanketing his his his mistakes,
right, and his his his issues over, oh,
he's God, so he's good, right? Whatever.
You know, he revealed all these
scriptures. He sent all these prophets
with a message, and somehow everything
got corrupted except for Muhammad's,
right? That doesn't make any sense. You
have 25 prophets in your religion. So
everything is just missing, you know,
conveniently except for Muhammad's that
by by by by definition of someone being
untrustworthy. That's exactly what
Muhammad is. Like anybody in their right
mind would say, "I can't trust you if
that's what you're saying." Now, with
this being said, right, would it make
sense for you to, you know, philosophy
the way that you did around it and then
go into your Quran and read a verse,
chapter 2:es 2-5, where he says, "A
successful and rightfully guided Muslim
is one who believes in all of what Allah
has revealed." So, why would he let it
all get corrupt and then tell you that
you can only be successful and
rightfully guided in his eyes if you
believe in all of it?
>> What sense does that make?
>> No, no, that's a fantastic question.
It's a very good question. So I think
there's a few things to take into
consideration. The first thing is say I
would say I would not say that Allahh
made a mistake by allowing these books
to get corrupted. In fact it's an even
bigger evidence to the legitimacy of the
Quran because after400 years there's
still not a single word that's been
changed in the Quran. Right. So if
anything that just reaffirms the
validity of the Quran. Um now as far as
to the second part of your question um
sorry do you mind repeating the second
part of your question? Yeah, he allowed
it to get corrupted but then told you to
believe in it in chapter 2:es 2-5.
Right. So chapter
>> how does that how do you know what
you're believing in?
>> No, I agree. So here's basically the way
that works, right? Uh Allah says in
chapter 2 of the Quran that right I'm
just going to say in Arabic and
translate in English if that's okay.
Right?
That is the book that has no doubt
within it.
Right. It's a guide to those who
believe.
Okay. So that would basically
translation would be it would be the
people who obey and worship Allah and
they believe in what has been sent down
to him or should I say sent down to the
prophet Muhammad. Right? So the thing
that we have to believe in is right
here. This is essentially the
compilation of the previous books the
parts.
>> Yeah. But I I don't know why you guys
like I don't know why you guys do this.
Please finish the rest of the verse and
read verse five.
>> Okay. You want me to read verse five
specifically?
>> No. I want you to finish verse four
because you cut it in half. Please read
the rest of the verse and verse five.
>> Uh, sorry, that was verse three that I
stopped at. Let me go ahead and get that
for you real quick. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Two through Yeah, two through
five.
>> Okay, no worries, my friend. One through
>> By the way, Muhammad, are you a Sunni?
>> I am.
>> Okay. Well, it's nice to meet you, man.
You're definitely uh different so far
from the guests we've had today. So,
it's really pleasant.
>> Oh, yeah. For sure.
>> Refreshing.
>> I just I believe that the root of any
faith is kindness. So, I just try to be
kind to everybody.
>> That's good. Um so yeah it says
which translates to this is the book
there is no doubt about it a guide for
those mindful of Allah I just want to
pull up the translation just to make
sure that you know I have a fair
translation for everybody who believe in
the unseen establish prayer and donate
from what we have provided for them and
who believe in what has been revealed to
you oh prophet and what was revealed
before you and have sure faith in the
hereafter and this is verses five it is
they who are truly guided by their lord
and is they who will be successful
So which way can you be truly guided by
Allah and successful?
>> Which way can you be truly guided by
Allah and successful by believing and
what was sent to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam.
>> Why did you stop there? Can you read
verse four again?
>> Yeah. And who believe in what has been
revealed to you, O prophet, and what was
revealed before you and have sure faith
in the hereafter.
>> Right. So when I asked you how do you be
successful and rightfully guided by
Allah, right? You just said believe in
what was revealed to the prophet. That
verse didn't say that.
>> Sorry. Okay. So, the Arabic, let me do
the direct translation because I was
reading the the English translation.
I'll be very fair to you guys, right?
I'll read the Arabic itself and
translate word for word.
Which means I'm sorry, one second.
Somebody's texting me. Let me just mute
my notifications. Yeah.
>> No worries.
>> To the person that sent me a message. I
appreciate the heads up. Um,
and those who believe
for that which was sent to you, revealed
to you, right? So in Arabic, the term,
right, is a it's a it's a linguistic
thing, right? Which it tells you to you
specifically
and that which was revealed before you
and they will have faith in the
hereafter. Does that make sense?
>> Right. Yeah. So what was revealed before
Muhammad?
So what was revealed before Muhammad was
basically the same message of Allahhana
tala right which was that there's only
one god and there's basically
>> no I would like uh books like what books
what revelation was revealed before
Muhammad
>> the books themselves uh there was and
the zabur
>> thank you so now let's so now let's take
it back to this first step right so we
know it's not just the Quran that your
god tells you to believe in so now with
your statement of oh he just allowed all
the scriptures to get corrupted well Why
in the world in his last revelation that
you think is real revelation, is he
telling you that the only way you can be
rightfully guided and successful to him
is if you believe in all of what he
revealed, but yet you're telling us he
let it all get corrupted. Does that make
sense to you?
>> No, no, I understand what you're saying.
It's a valid point. And the main thought
process here, right, in the breakdown,
and I think, you know, the most
reasonable thing for us to do is
understand, you know, the context of it.
What it's saying is that we have to
believe in Jesus. You cannot be a Muslim
and not believe in Jesus and believe
that a book was sent to him. So the
initial message oh Jesus is something
that all Muslims have to accept and the
same thing applies to the Indian. Now if
you're asking how can we follow that if
it can be you know there's different
belief systems and you know like it's
been corrupted and whatnot the best way
to do so is this is why you know in
Arabic it was presented like this part
was first is to show that this is a more
valid thing. The Quran validates a lot
of things in the Torah and it validates
other things in the the and it validates
you know many things. It validates a lot
of elements. So the way that we do this,
for example, I have like a scientific
background. So what happens is if I find
some data, I could actually match it
with other theories and whatnot and find
out which one's the most valid, but then
there's some aspects that don't align
and the parts that don't
>> m you're matching it with what? What?
What are you matching it with?
>> With other theories and belief systems.
So for example, if we know like we still
have some elements because we believe
that the Bible was corrupt like
corrupted, right? But not so Okay. So
okay, I'm confused here. So before we
get into all of that, right? Um, let's
just go back to square one, right?
>> So, you do believe in a religion with
corrupted scripture.
>> We believe in a religion
>> because it seems like you're parsing out
how to answer my question with corrupted
scripture according to
>> because here's the thing. I believe in a
religion that has multiple scriptures in
the p that were sent in the past and
some of them were corrupted, which is
why the Quran was sent to validate which
information we to keep. I think
>> so. So you do believe So you do believe
in a rel It's a very simple question. So
you do believe in a religion with
corrupted scripture. Earlier you said
no.
>> And then and then and then you as after
we built the conversation we find out
the scriptures you do believe in your
religion are corrupted.
>> No. Because here's the thing. If you
don't mind me answering that question,
right? If you pull up a Bible right now,
right? If you hold up a Bible and you
ask me, is this the corrupted version? I
will say yes. I believe Muhammad
Muhammad where Muhammad where are your
scriptures in your religion? Where are
your scriptures? Where where is the
original Torah the original the original
psalms that Allah sent down and they had
with them reading and and and and you
know passing on the message where where
where is it today
>> there? I mean there isn't really any
legitimate like full copies that
actually still exist
>> because you believe it's been corrupted,
right?
>> Parts of it. Many parts of it have. Yes.
>> Thank you. These are Islamic scriptures,
>> right? So that's why I'm saying I don't
understand.
>> So in Islam, your Islamic scriptures
have been corrupted.
>> In Islam, the previous scriptures have
been corrupted. People have corrupted
them in past. Yes, I'll say so. Yes.
>> So you do follow a religion with
corrupted scripture. And it's not only
that. The majority of your scriptures in
your religion have been corrupted.
>> Can I can I go ahead and refute that
then?
>> Well, I would like for you to answer yes
or no because
>> Oh, here's the thing. Yes or no is a
great way to not have a proper
conversation.
>> Well, no, you've been explaining. We've
let you explain. Now, we need to figure
out what it is that you believe because
now I'm confused.
>> Okay, I'll tell you. I'll explain it
very very simply. Okay,
>> but but is it a yes or no first? You got
you got you can't you you got to be
honest. We let you explain
>> a lot because here's the thing. I'm
answering your question, then you
respond, and now you want me to be label
you want to have an in-depth
conversation. You're limiting me to two
words,
>> Muhammad. Muhammad, we had an Muhammad,
we had an indepth conversation first.
And then when I let you build to get an
idea of what it is that you're you're
you're you're teaching us right now,
then that's when I said, "Okay, wait. We
got to stop now because I'm confused."
At first you said one thing, then you
said another thing, then you did it
again, and now you're doing it again now
because you're not concluding. You're
just telling us what these books is and
who they were given to and what your
religion believes about believing in
them. I'm not asking you that. I'm
asking you, do you follow a religion
with corrupted scripture? You're opting
out of answering that question for some
reason.
>> Right? So, this is a simple way to
answer your question. Then, if we want
to have a constructive conversation,
this is a simple way to answer the
question. Okay? I believe in the
original Bible. The original Bible is a
compilation of stories. Where can I find
those answers? In the Quran. Give me a
second.
>> I'm not asking you where to find any
answers. I'm not asking you what you
believe in. I'm asking you, do you
follow a religion with corrupted
scripture? Why are you dodging that
question?
>> I think the main reason while literally
telling us yes,
>> I'm trying to make sure I'm trying to
make sure that I'm making it clear that
I don't follow the corrupted books. Do I
believe in a religion where the books
have been corrupted? Yes.
>> Are these corrupted books in your
religion?
>> Does my religion believe these books
have been corrupted? Are these re are
these books revealed by your God making
it a part of your religion?
>> The books have been revealed by God. The
books are part of
>> which make thank you. So within your
religion, majority of the books that are
revealed by your God have been
corrupted.
>> The majority of the books have been
corrupted. Yes.
>> So you believe in a religion with
corrupted scripture. Not only that, the
majority of your scriptures have been
corrupted,
>> I would say. So actually, yeah,
>> thank you. So earlier you said you
wouldn't follow a religion with
corrupted scripture. Now we find out
it's even worse. You follow a religion
where majority of its scriptures have
been corrupted.
>> Okay. So can I go ahead and answer now
or I'm going to let you finish your
point?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Sure.
>> I'll go ahead and answer it. I
misunderstood your question and that's
my fault. Okay. So I'll own that. Do I
follow a religion with corrupted
scriptures? Right? The way that that
question is phrased can be taken in two
ways. Are there corrupted scriptures
that are part of the story of the
religion, part of the breakdown? Of
course. Do we follow those corrupted
scriptures? No, we don't follow those
corrupted scriptures. That's where I was
getting stuck. So, is does it like is
the story of the zab and included in
Islam and does is say that they are
corrupted? Absolutely. So, within the
religion are these types of stories. We
do accept that these things have
happened. So that is within the religion
but that is not the religion right. So
we believe in the for example we believe
in the the Torah right we believe in the
message of the we believe in that
message because all these scriptures are
sent as messages. So we believe in them
right but we don't believe in the sense
of where we'll follow them even after
they've been corrupted. So they become a
part of the religion and so the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was brought
he was sent to us to with the Quran
which aggregates all the key messages
that were supposed to be in the Torah in
the Injil and every other book that was
corrupted eventually. So are those
previous things part of the religion in
the sense of like the story the lineage
of how it works? Of course I will accept
it all day. Will I say that we follow
all those books? No, I won't say that.
So that's kind of where I think it was
more so just the way that the question
was phrased. I wanted to make sure that
I'm being very clear and I think that's
a fair thing. Why don't you say so?
>> I think it I think I think what happened
here, bro, is that you answered early on
>> and you just tried to clean it up with
whatever you just said. I understand
what you're saying. Still doesn't change
the fact that now we realize you
actually have the religion that's full
of corrupted scripture. You are the one
that follows an untrustworthy religion.
And you know that this makes a religion
untrustworthy because the first thing
that came out of your mouth was no. And
now we find out you actually do follow a
religion with corrupted scripture and
you just tried to clean it up.
>> So why wouldn't you follow a religion
with corrupted scripture?
>> If I can be a bit more fair, I I do feel
like the question that you were asking
was, you know, it it was set up in a
weird way because it could mean one
thing or another thing depending on the
way that you were asking it.
>> No, but we figured it out. Yeah, we
figured it out together. We did. I
agree. But I just want you to understand
that's where my hesitation was cuz when
I said yes, I was I wasn't sure of the
specific context that you were asking
the question. So that's kind of why I
was trying to get this clarification.
>> But but we figured that out already. We
we
>> So you do agree you follow a religion
with corrupted scripture.
>> We follow the religion that includes
that speaks of corrupted scriptures.
Yes.
>> No. Not speaks of them. Come on.
>> Hold on.
Real quick. I just want to say something
real quick. I just want to say something
real quick because the way that whenever
you ask that question and we can ask the
chat if they want to be fair we can even
ask the audience when you say you follow
something with
>> right
>> well for example if I'm following my
road home and I follow it with a map
>> right then that shows that I like my
whole way of navigating is with this map
>> okay
>> right and that's kind of the thing for
me I only navigate Islam with one book
and that's the Quran
>> yeah but hold on pause there I
understand what you're saying is but is
Islam is Islam navigated through one
book or through four.
>> Is Islam navigated with one book or
through four? It's with one book which
compiles the messages of four.
>> No. See, and and that's what's wrong
because Okay. So, so for example,
Muhammad um and I and I like this
direction we can go into. What is the
reason that Well, let's start with this.
The Torah, the Psalms, the Gospel, these
were Islamic scriptures. Correct.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, so before there was a Quran,
Islam was navigated by three other
books, right?
>> The the Psalms. Sorry, real quick. The
Gospel and the Psalms are both uh part
of the Bible, though. No.
>> Yes. Yeah. The the Bi the Bible is a
compilation of all these different
books.
>> The Bible. Okay, that makes sense.
Sorry. That was good, man.
>> Okay. So, the Torah, Psalms, and Gospel,
these are three books in which Islam was
navigated through before there was a
Quran, right? And then the Quran came
not as an exclusion of those but as a
complement to those as a confirmation of
those right
>> of the original books. Yeah.
>> So that means that Islam Hold on there's
like a little echo. It might be you mute
my let's test it up. Hold on. Don't
don't do anything. Muhammad testing
testing testing testing. Okay. I don't
hear myself anymore. Okay. It looks like
we're all right for now. All right. So
>> Oh, I have my headphones up on accident.
my headphones on the speaker.
>> Life reacts, man. My God.
>> All right. Okay. So, so we see that um
that Islam is not just navigated through
one book, Muhammad, right? But it's
navigated through four. The Torah,
Psalms, Gospel, and the Quran, right? So
that means that if you say that, oh,
well, I only navigate Islam through the
Quran. You can't do that because Islam
itself is not navigated through just one
book. It's navigated through all four.
Okay? So, you have to include all of
those. This is why we have to we that's
why we're like pressing on this and
making sure the wording is correct that
you follow a religion. If if the other
three Torah, Psalms, Gospel got
corrupted, these are Islamic scriptures.
These are books within Islam that got
corrupted eventually over time while the
Quran is the only one that's preserved.
So you still have a religion with only
one preserved book and three corrupted
ones.
>> Okay, that's a good question. That's a
great question and I'll answer that. But
real quick, I just want to ask you guys
a favor though. Once we're done with
this, I want to ask some questions, too.
Is that fair?
>> That's fair.
>> All right, I appreciate that, man. So,
here's basically like the main thing.
Obviously, like I said, we don't believe
that the pre these books have been, you
know, like the the underlying message
and the key messages have been
preserved, right? So, that's kind of why
it's really important for us to
recognize and every book is sent the
same message, the same underlying
messages, right? Which is you believe in
one God, you know, be good to your
neighbor, these types of things. But
then whenever it started to get corrupt,
whenever human beings start tossing
their own little elements of it, it kind
of became different. So, in every one of
those books, there's a common themes,
right, which is the message of Islam.
believe in one God, pray to God, obey
God, give charity, all that type of
stuff. That's why ultimately whenever we
come to the Quran, the Quran is the
final version where it contains the same
exact message, right? But it breaks it
down in a way where it's very very
valid, right? In the sense of it hasn't
been corrupted by human beings. So what
you know to your question is do we
believe in the previous books and
whatnot? Of course, we believe that they
were once there, but we can't say that
we use those as a valid way to kind of
navigate the religion. That's why the
Islam was sent as a clarification. It's
mentioned in the Quran that it's a
clarification to help us understand the
religion.
>> Okay. So, there's a there's there's so
many things I want to I want to touch
on. I feel like I feel like this part we
got, you know, um I I want to touch on
the the fundamental
the fundamental uh part of your argument
is that the Quran came to clarify the
previous scriptures. Um you don't
believe in what they are now or
whatever. I want to I want to touch on
this. Okay. Um, would you would you
agree that the announcement of another
messenger coming is important to the
message being delivered?
>> Sorry, one sec. I'm getting a call. Let
me just Goodness, I'm in high demand all
of a sudden.
>> That's what happens. It's only when you
go live. It's only when you go live that
everybody calls. Everybody texts. That's
the only time That's the only time my
mom calls me is when I'm live, man.
Goodness. Love you, mama.
>> Got to love your mom though. Anyways,
can you repeat your question?
>> Yeah. So, would you agree that um
>> Oh, he's getting another call.
>> Oh, yeah. So, that was that that that
was him then.
>> Yeah. This echo.
>> Was that me? I'm sorry, guys. Back up
the
>> Yeah, it's it's you echoing. Yeah.
>> Okay. Hold on. Let me mute myself.
>> Wait, I don't want to do that. I don't
want to have to It had to be like that
though cuz it was It was good earlier
than it switched.
>> I don't think it was that bad though.
>> Yeah, it's okay.
>> You guys want to drop me and bring me
back up? Would that help reset? I don't
know how your Do you have anything else
on or do you have It's connected to
Bluetooth or something?
>> Uh, you just connected to my charger.
>> It might have been sometime.
>> Is your phone really close to the to the
to the desk? Like the bottom of the
desk?
>> Is this better?
>> We'll see. Yo yo yo.
>> Test one, two, three. Test one, two,
three.
>> Yeah, we can still hear ourselves, but
we'll just have to work. Yeah, it was
echoing off your table.
>> Gotcha. My bad.
But okay. So would you agree that uh
that the announcement of another prophet
to come is important to the message
being shared?
>> Would I agree that the announcement of
another prophet? Sorry, which message
are we talking about though?
>> Any of them. If any message included
that another prophet was coming, would
you consider that to be important to the
message?
>> Yeah, of course. Yeah, absolutely. So
now this is what is supposed to be
portrayed in the angil and the Torah.
The Quran doesn't portray this obviously
because Muhammad's supposed to be the
last. He's supposed to be the last
prophet. He's the seal of the prophets.
So he doesn't have this message that
somebody else is coming. He says I'm it,
right? The other the other ones or the
other books have part of their message
is that the unlettered prophet is coming
and we're to follow him and when he
comes recognize him because he's in line
with what you have. That's the me that's
part of the message of the Torah and the
gospel. Right? So,
>> okay,
>> with this being said, this is a reason
why the Jews and the Christians should
accept Muhammad and what he's what's
being revealed to him, the Quran,
because he's already mentioned in their
scriptures and he's in line with what
they have. Can we agree with that?
>> Yeah. I mean, if the Quran mentioned the
prophet, you know, and said like, you
know, the long hair or something like
that and somebody came similarly, I
would say it would be valid to really
consider it. I agree.
>> Yeah. So, for example, we have verses
where the Quran is apprehending the Jews
and Christians and and like um I
wouldn't I don't think apprehending is
the best word. Uh um basically they're
in trouble. They're in trouble with
Allah because they're rejecting
Muhammad. And his response to them is
Muhammad is coming with something
confirming what you have. It's
confirming your scriptures. It's
confirming the Torah and Gospel. So
believe in what we have sent down.
Right? So the a a proof that Muhammad
should be accepted and a proof that he
truly is a prophet and the Quran is
really from God is that it confirms the
scriptures the Jews and Christians have
in Muhammad's time. You understand what
I'm saying?
>> Um I'm not quite. So you're saying that
uh the scriptures in the past have
spoken about Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam coming and sorry what
was he saying that though? and that the
Quran is in line with what these
scriptures teach there. It's in line
with the Torah and the Gospel.
>> Are you quoting this from your books or
from my books?
>> From yours.
>> Okay. Do you know like what verse it is?
>> Yeah, there's there's a few. So, if we
go with uh if we you we were in chapter
2 earlier. We can stay there. Chapter 2
verse 41.
>> One moment, please. I just like to do it
because you know in uh Islamic uh you
know studies I guess um we always talk
about certain things right for example
the reasons for uh revelation the
context and what not it's all very
important so I don't want to you know
explain elaborate without you know
giving you guys a fair thing what was
the verse that you mentioned
>> chapter 2 verse 41
>> 41 okay
here just okay
>> right so it says believe in what I have
sent down right or revealed believe in
what I have revealed confirm confirming
that which is with you, right? And do
not mix my truth with falsehood and
stuff like that. So here the the Allah
is telling the people of the book um and
in context the Jews specifically to
believe in the Quran because it's it
confirms what's with them, what they
have,
>> right? And obviously they have the
Torah. So this would mean that the the
Quran is saying that the Torah they have
is true. The Quran is in line with the
Torah they have. and therefore they
ought to believe in Muhammad in the
Quran. They shouldn't reject him.
>> Okay. So I think that you know regarding
that point that's another great question
actually. Um so in this specific context
is with the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he was talking to the people of
the book specifically the Jews I
believe. Um the main thing like the
reason why and it's also mentioned in
other parts of the Quran. One of the
things that it talks about was the
unlettered prophet right? So I think the
best way for us to look at is if we were
actually there at the time of the
prophet peace be upon him. So if you
were to go to him and you have your
books and you're talking to a man who
literally cannot read and they know he
cannot read too, right? And he says and
you sit there and saying like, "Oh, like
proof to us that you're, you know, like
an actual prophet or whatnot." And he
comes up and he confirms what's in your
Torah. Meaning there's certain aspects
where I said there's overlap. If he sits
here and tells you this, you know, the
story of Noah, the story of Moses, or
just very specific things, it makes
perfect sense for you to be like, "Okay,
hold on. How does he know that?" So
that's why in this specific verse it's
talking about listen if you have your
books right the parts that you still
have and you believe what not and he's
telling you what's in your books even
though he cannot read right that's a way
of you him valid and confirming listen
he knows what he's talking about he's
the one that you've been told about
>> because like I said not not the entire
Torah has been completely wiped only
parts of it
>> yeah so and that's where my problem is
is because we don't see where it says
that part of it is being confirmed it
just simply blatantly just confirms
confirms what's with them. Period. It
doesn't say um believe in what we have
what I have revealed to you, confirming
some of what is with you. Confirming
part of what is with you. It just simply
says in general confirming what is with
you, right? And so that means that what
is with them, which is the Torah, the
writings of the prophets, obviously all
that stuff, all of that is true. It's
it's preserved and it's authoritative.
And the Quran says that about it and
therefore they should believe in all of
it. They should believe in Muhammad cuz
he's in line with that. It wouldn't it
wouldn't make sense if those were
corrupted. Sorry if Go ahead. You was
about to start. Go ahead.
>> No, no, no. That's fine. I I cut you
off. Sorry. I'm Please finish the point
that you had though.
>> It would it wouldn't make sense if these
books were corrupted that they have if
the Torah that they had with them in
Muhammad's time was corrupted. It
wouldn't make sense for Allah to say,
"Believe in what I've revealed to you
sent down revealed confirming what is
with you." If what is with them is
corrupted, that would mean that the
Quran is confirming a corrupted book.
>> Right? So here's the way that I would,
you know, want to explain this. Now, on
this notepad, on the other side of it,
of course, I've written down five words.
Right? Obviously, you don't know what
those words are. Nobody here knows what
those words are except for me. Right?
Now, if you were to tell sit down and
tell me right now three of the words
that are written here, that would be
enough for me to be like, hold on, how
do you know these things? How did you
validate what I have here? It might not
be all of it, but you have enough of it.
Three out of five is a crazy amount,
right? That's more than 50%. So, this is
kind of like the same context. It's
saying like he's going to come in and
tell you what's in your books, even
though he's never seen it. That is a
miracle for an unlettered prophet to be
able to tell you what you have, even if
he's not going to say every single
thing. The prophet didn't sit there and
just break down the entire Torah. He
just validated it, especially the parts
that were still relevant. Now, of
course, here's the other thing that I
also like to add, if you don't mind.
Whenever it says that it's going to
confirm your scriptures, right? Now, if
we have the initial scripture itself, if
we have the initial scripture itself and
I add stuff to it, right, which is where
we believe that it got corrupted. If I
add stuff to it, him coming in and
saying what's added to it will prove
that he's a false prophet, wouldn't it?
Because if he's specifically talking
about what's in the scriptures that you
have, everything that you've added is
not part of the scriptures. He's only
going to address the parts that are
truly the scriptures. Does that make
sense? Everything that you add to it,
that doesn't count.
>> Yes, that would make sense. Which is why
we would expect if this was the case
that Allah would say, "Hey, what you
have is corrupted. Don't follow that.
Here's the true parts. This is what is
true and this is what is false in those
scriptures." But Allah doesn't do that.
What he does is he confirms what they
have in general. Number number two is
that Muhammad isn't oblivious to this
these stories around. These stories are
popular. This isn't just something that
oh no one knows this about only the Jews
and Christians know this and nobody else
is hearing about this. No, these stories
are popular. There's a lot of oral
traditions going around. Muhammad was a,
you know, dealt with caravans and was
close with wara who was skilled with the
Torah and gospel. Um, was around the
Jews who used to recite the Torah in
Arabic and I'm sorry, in uh Hebrew and
then explain it in Arabic, right? So,
he's familiar with these with traditions
and these oral stories that's going
around. So, it's not going to which is
>> Say that say that again.
>> Sorry. I'm so sorry. I I didn't write
down your first point and it was a good
thing to talk about. Can you repeat the
first point too before you started
mentioning how like the stories have
could have been heard from other people?
>> Oh, that uh you that you we would expect
if he's only confirming part of the
scripture and making sure that he's not
confirming the corrupted parts. We would
expect him to announce what parts are
corrupted and hold them to what is
specifically intact instead of, you
know, referring to what they have as a
whole. But that's what we see. What we
see is that Allah refers to what they
have as a whole. He says the Torah and
with you, the scriptures you have with
you. He doesn't say part of it or this
part of the scripture you have with you
or you know he doesn't do that. He
refers to them as a whole. So that gives
us the indication I think very clearly
that the scriptures they have according
to the Quran are not corrupted. They
can't be or else Allah is just either
purposely, you know, confirming
corrupted books or he's not, he doesn't
know they're corrupted. He's doing this
by mistake.
>> Okay. Sorry. And then you can go ahead
with go to second place. Well, I just
want to make sure
>> I I don't want it to be too long. We
could do one one thing at a time. So,
you you could deal with that first.
>> Okay. Sounds good. Um, so what I'm going
to go ahead and do real quick, if you
don't mind, um, I'm just going to pull
up verses from Bakar, which was, you
know, I just feel like it's, you know, I
really liked what you said about
sticking to the same chapter. Uh, so I'm
going to go ahead and pull that as well.
I just got to have it generated. And
folks in the chat, I was getting chewed
out earlier because I had to look this
up. I'm sorry I don't have the whole
Quran memorized. I hope to one day.
>> You going to 279?
>> I'm going to uh chapter 275.
>> I just want to see what it says real
quick.
>> Yeah. So, what I just do is I just look
for like the general context and look at
the specifics. Sure.
>> I know everybody wants like very fast
rapid fire answers, but it just takes me
a second to find
>> Hey, man. Man, we we're we're in this
together, man. We one step at a time to
understanding. You're not in a rush.
You're not in a rush here.
>> I'm more than happy to, by the way,
answer questions and have these debates.
I love it and I really appreciate it's
been respectable. I've seen some other
things on TikTok where people are
cussing out each other's gods and it
just horrifies me and it horrifies me
from both sides. As Muslims, we're not
even allowed to cuss out another
person's god.
>> Yeah. It's it's disgust. It's disgusting
on both ends. We we rather have these
type of conversations. That's why I said
when when you came up, you're vastly
different from the previous guests that
we had. Like we had like four guests
before you. Very different.
>> It's an emotional thing, right? This is
talking about the most important thing
in somebody's life. So sometimes
emotions can cloud judgment. But every
religion preaches patience, right? Okay.
Okay. So there's a uh the first thing
that I want to address, right? The part
about how, you know, while the prophet
could have listened to any stories while
he's talking to other people, he could
have picked it up. he was hanging out um
you know with uh which by the way is a
brilliant mind of the time. So that's
that's a very very good point. So the
first thing that I would say regard he
only went to after he got revelation
right he was introduced to on that night
from what I was taught at least right no
>> because he was a relative
>> well sorry well here's the point that
I'm just making as far as what we were
taught but even then even then let's say
that they were boys from the beginning
of time sure that right again I'm just
saying what I just heard one time but I
can't quote the Quran so therefore or
hadith
>> they were they were very familiar with
each other they were close
>> which Excellent. But even then at the
end of the like the end point is this.
So even at the time of the prophet when
this verse was revealed right the Jews
of course knew of this guy was known
throughout the lands. He was a brilliant
brilliant mind. He wasn't even a Muslim
himself actually right. So when he came
by right and whenever the prophet was
hanging out with him of course the Jews
themselves could have said hey listen
you know you picked this up from but
that wasn't even an argument that they
used. Yes, it was
>> even at well no cuz it got refuted
though ultimately right cuz they said
like oh what if you pick this up said
ask me something specific and that's
also mentioned in the Quran. So
ultimately the main reason why I bring
that if it was I can pull up the verse
if you give me a second
>> brother they they literally accused
Muhammad of getting of repeating stories
and of old that they already know and
that they're that he's getting from
others.
>> But hold on there that's true but they
came with a reputation. Let me go and
pull it up for you real quick. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Uh oh my gosh. Okay. Mhm.
>> But remember this is this is secondary.
The main the main issue is is if the the
uh the scriptures are corrupted from the
Quran standpoint.
>> Okay. Uh
>> thank you guys for the super chats. I
appreciate you guys. We got,00 people
here on TikTok watching. We got 2500 on
YouTube. Everybody on YouTube make sure
you guys hit the like button. Every
single one of you guys. We should have
2,000 likes on YouTube, guys. Come on.
>> We're on YouTube.
>> Yes, we're on YouTube and Tik Tok. like
a YouTube live.
>> Yep.
>> Nice. Okay.
Okay. I feel like I'm trying to do this
quick research at the speed of sound.
>> It's okay, bro. You like like I said,
that's that's way secondary. You know
what I'm saying? That's way secondary.
You can just let's let's let's get to
the let's stick to the main point. Okay.
>> Okay. Sure. Uh the main point that you
were discussing earlier, right, which
was that if the books were corrupted, um
right, then why did Allah not clarify
that they were corrupted?
>> Right. Correct. which is, you know,
interesting point because um somebody
said 73 what I was looking at.
>> Why why does he do the why does he do
the opposite? Instead of saying that
they're corrupted, what he does is is he
affirms their scriptures. He affirms
them as true and confirms them and tells
them to believe in the Quran because
it's in line with what they currently
have. That's we see the opposite, you
know.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, I'll tell you this,
okay? Uh I think the main thing here is
first and foremost obviously this is me
giving you know uh context to it right
we can't speak on behalf of God but
sometimes God gives us points that we
can kind of use right so with that being
said in this specific area uh we know
that historically when revelation came
down and the prophet was speaking to a
specific people right more than one time
in the past has it been valid to where
you speak in a way that's more so
building bridges and building walls
right so in this specific context your
argument would have been 110% valid
if if he said that your books are not
corrupted. But it just says it validates
what they have. Right? That's kind of
like the key thing because nowhere in
the Quran does it say that injil is not
corrupted. Nowhere in the Quran does it
say that the Torah is not corrupted. So
that specific detail that you're asking
about, right? It's not there in this
specific context, but it's not there in
the entire book saying that like this is
these books are valid. They're
completely in fact it's already
clarified in other parts of the Quran.
When you're talking to someone,
>> what what does it mean to confirm
something?
>> Well, to confirm something like I said
is to kind of validate it, right? So for
example, I gave you the example of the
five words I have right here. Right?
Right. So now you can see it.
>> So if if I if I say I confirm the words
that's on that sticky note, that means
that I've validated it, right? That I
I'm saying that those words are true on
that sticky note, right?
>> If you were to say, for example, if you
were the the messenger of God, right?
And you say, I'm going to validate what
you have and you use all five words,
that would be validating all five.
>> No, just no. Just simply no, if I simply
say th the the the words on the sticky
note that you have the sticky note that
you have I confirm it. What what am I
doing with that sticky note? What am I
saying about it?
>> You're saying that it's correct.
>> Exactly. So I don't have to say so I
don't have to say that sticky note is
not corrupted. I've already said it's
correct which means it's not corrupted.
Something that's corrupted is not
correct. Can we agree?
>> Sorry. Can we repeat the last thing you
said you cut out? Something that is
corrupted by definition is incorrect. Do
we agree?
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So if I'm saying something is
correct, if I'm confirming something
which means I'm saying it's correct,
>> that means that by definition it's not
corrupted.
>> Right.
>> So Allah he says that he's confirming he
confirms the Torah and the Gospel, the
scriptures that's with the Jews and
Christians. meaning that he's already
eliminated this idea that they're
corrupted. He already said that what
they have currently is correct.
>> Well, again, the only way that you can
validate that is the things that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
validates it, right? So, like I said, if
you said all five words, then it
confirms everything that I have. If you
confirmed a third of it, that means
you're confirming only a third of what I
have. So, that's kind of like the key
point that I'm trying to establish here.
>> What if I don't mean to cut you off, but
I'm so sorry. I'm so But this is it's
important. I'm sorry, Muhammad. If I say
>> I love the fact.
>> Okay, thanks. If I say I confirm that
sticky note, right, with the that has
the five words on it, right? I don't say
I confirm I don't necessarily point out
specifically the words, but I just say
in general I confirm that sticky note.
>> Does that include the five the five uh
sentences you or five words on the
sticky note?
>> You're saying that you confirm the
sticky note as a whole?
>> Yeah. If I say that validate it,
>> say yeah. If I say I confirm the sticky
note you have, does that include the
five words that are on that sticky note?
>> I think that this would kind of fall
into the question similarly to how Life
Reacts question was at first. Right. So
I can see what you're saying. I do. I I
hear you, right? Like it finally
clicked. I know what you're trying to
establish. So the first thing that I
would want to say is in this specific
verse, right? It's saying that it's
going to confirm from what they have.
Right? So in the Arabic um sorry I
closed the You got you got you got to
answer this first.
>> Yeah. No, I got you. I'm just pulling
I'm trying to pull that verse back up
for you real quick.
>> Okay.
>> That same exact verse. Which one was
again?
>> Uh 241.
>> Uh I know 241. All right. Close that.
>> So So if I say I confirm that sticky
note, that would include all the five
words on the sticky note, right?
>> Sorry, one second. I'm just reading it.
Okay. Okay, I hear you. Yes. Yes, you're
100% right.
>> Awesome.
>> So that's that's very true. It says in
the verse
Right? So believe in what I've sent down
to you guys. Right?
Is the key thing right here. Right?
Means to the one who's with you.
>> Say that again.
>> Right. To the one who's with I said
is to the one who's with you.
>> No, not to the one that's with you.
>> No, not not to the one.
>> That's what
>> it means. So madik confirming lima,
right? what is with you? So what is with
them? The Quran is confirming it. It has
confirmed it. So they have the Torah,
they have the gospel. So what is with
them? The Quran is saying is correct.
>> What I'm saying though is we never said
that they had the whole thing.
>> It's validating the parts that they
have.
>> That's kind of where Now you're going to
draw the circle. Hold on. I'm going live
to draw the circle.
>> See, it's it's not that. Notice notice
how it doesn't say that it's confirming
a particular portion. It says it's
confir There's life. It says it's
confirming what is with them. Not part
of what is with them. Like similar with
me and you. I said I'm confirming your
sticky note. I didn't say I'm confirming
the fourth word on your sticky note. I
said I'm confirming your sticky note.
Which means all the words that's on that
sticky note are correct. from my
standpoint. So the same thing here with
the Quran, it's confirming not part of
what is with you, not some of what is
with you, it's confirming what is with
you. Meaning that whatever they have,
the Quran is saying is correct.
>> So let me ask you a question then, okay?
Because I think I I hear your argument
again. It's a great argument, right?
Fantastic. Well done. So here's the
point that I want to give back to you,
though, right? Now, if you're saying
that, you know, the the sticky note,
this is first of all, the the the verse,
of course, we know it's talking to the
prophet, telling him, listen, tell them
to believe and everything that's been
revealed to you, what not, right?
>> So, the way that you verify, your way of
verifying it was by saying everything
that you have, right? I'm validating it
for you.
>> Yes.
>> And that would be a great approach if it
was a political thing, right? Because
that would be like, okay, I'm
validating. Get you get them to love
what you're saying, get them to support
you. It's a great approach. It's a good
It's a good move. Yes,
>> it's a great move. Right. But the
difference here is that while you're
saying this sticky note, everything that
you have, I'm validating it. What this
specific context was was trying to prove
it was trying to prove that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam prophet peace
be upon him was the one who was actually
presenting this information from God. So
the thing is it wasn't him trying to
verify them. It was them trying to
verify him. And that's a big difference
here. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
pause, wait, wait, pause, cuz this is
important. I I agree somewhat with what
you're saying, but I think it's a little
backwards.
>> Who here is trying to verify Muhammad in
the in the text?
>> The Jewish people.
>> No,
>> the Jewish people or
>> Allah
>> Allah is trying is verifying Allah is
the one trying to verify Muhammad to the
people. He's trying to show
>> Allah is
>> Yes. Allah is the one.
>> No, hold on.
>> Go ahead.
>> So amongst the people, right? amongst
the people, the Jewish people did not
believe in Muhammad. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So it wasn't that he didn't trust their
books or anything like that in this
specific context. I know of course in
the grand church, correct?
>> Right. In this specific context, it was
them who didn't trust him.
>> Right? And and so what and so what is
the answer that Allah gives on why they
should trust him?
>> That's the key point here, right? So
Allahh tells them listen tell them tell
them of what has been revealed to you oh
Muhammad so they can look at their own
books and realize that there's parallels
there's parallels right okay hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on we're
alive
okay so here we are though okay here's
the key thing now man I got to say you
have awesome energy man so here's the
thing
>> in this specific context though right
because again the prophet's the one
who's getting scrutiny so the prophet's
not going to come up to somebody be
like, "Hey, listen. All your books, it's
legit." Because nobody's It was like,
"What the hell are you doing?" Right?
You're just trying to get me to feel
like I relate to you to understand what
the heck you're talking.
>> That's literally what he did. He
literally
>> All right. Go ahead.
>> Hold on. Let me mute you. Okay. That's
what Allahh told him to do. But how do
you do that? You don't walk up to
somebody say your books are legit.
Right? You've never read my book. For
example, I'm going to give you a
hypothetical thing so you can understand
where I'm coming from. Okay? Let's say
for example, uh I'm trying to get Man,
I'm blanking out on examples right now.
I'm trying to get, for example, I I want
you to like what I'm doing, right? I
want to build bridges with you. I'mma
come up to you and be like, listen, man,
>> right? Let's say I'm me as like not
Prophet Muhammad, but Muhammad the Tik
Tok guy, right? I'm not even a Tik Tok
guy, but you know,
>> if I want to build a bridge with you, I
could like, hey, listen, believe me what
I have to present to you, right? And
you're going to be like, why? Right?
Just like any other rational person,
right? and you strike me as a very
rational guy, so I appreciate that. So,
you're going to be like, "Why?" And I'm
going to be like, "Because your books
are legitimate." Now, add to this that
I'm somebody who's illiterate. You're
going to be like, "Dude, you're just
saying that. You don't even know what's
in my books." And that's where the key
difference comes in because while you
said the whole post-it note is validated
in this specific context, it's like,
"No, no, so tell us what's in your
books." And that's what the prophet
presented to them. He didn't come and
say, "Hey, listen. I'm telling you the
whole entire Torah is there. He's saying
that he's validating in that sense of
he's coming back. Listen, there's this
that happened. There's this that
happened. There's this that happened.
There's this that happened. Specifics
that they would only know with what they
have. They could reflect it because
these are not just regular people. These
are the scholars of scholars within the
Jews.
>> All right?
>> That's where the contest comes together.
That's where the whole thing comes as a
circle. All right?
>> As life reacts like
>> All right. So, let's let's think about
this, bro. Let's think about this on
what the text says. Let's be honest. a
little longer, but I really want to ask
my questions, too.
>> Okay, let's talk about what the text
says. Be honest with me.
Straightforward.
>> Does the text
>> I feel like I've been doing a good job
with that far.
>> I think you have, too. You've been
honest, right? So, that's why I trusted
you to be honest here.
>> Does the verse say that the Quran
confirms some of what they have or does
it say it just simply confirms what they
have? Meaning, in general,
>> right, this is back to our initial
thing. No, that detail was not included
about the quantity.
>> So I think it is because it gives a
blatant statement confirming what is
with you, right?
>> So to suggest that oh well it's only
confirming part of what is with them
would be an addition to the text and
something that it doesn't say nor is it
what it communicates.
In fact, you literally have a verse
where Allah hates when people do that.
He does not like, and this is in the
same chapter, by the way, he does not
like when people pick and choose the
parts of the scriptures they believe in
and the parts they reject. He says
they're disgraced in this life and
they're going to hell in the in the
hereafter. So Allah already sets this he
has this um this um standard that he
does not like cherrypickers. He does not
like people who believe in part of the
scripture and reject other parts. So it
doesn't make sense for Allah to say when
he's to say he confirms what is with you
but really mean he's only confirming
part of what is with them. But then go
ahead and say whoever believes in part
of the scripture and reject other parts
that you're going to go to hell and
you're disgraced for doing that if
that's what he's encouraging us to do.
So everything is the opposite. Go ahead.
You want
>> No, I was Can you repeat the
I was going to ask a question. I'm just
asking you to repeat the second part to
what you're saying though
>> that it doesn't make sense for Allah to
con um to condemn people for picking and
choosing the parts of scriptures they
want to believe in the parts of
scripture they believe belie in some
parts rejecting other parts but at the
same time that's exactly what he's
encouraging us to do that to to believe
in only some of the scripture and reject
other parts of the scripture it doesn't
make sense if that's what If he condemns
that that that's also what he's
encouraging us to do. Make sense?
>> He Okay. So he's what you're basically
saying is of course Allah says in the
Quran you can't just take and pick you
know there's no cherry picking Islam.
>> Yes.
>> Right. And then you're saying that
essentially by not giving this that
essentially it would be cherrypicking
>> by by what you're arguing. If you're
arguing that the Quran is only
confirming parts of the scriptures,
right? That means that you're believing
in parts and rejecting other parts.
>> It's not. No. No. It's not believing
parts of scriptures, right? We believe
in the whole true scripture and things
that human beings added. That's not part
of the scripture to begin with, right?
That's just some Reddit freestyle. If I
add a Bible verse right now, is that
part of the Bible?
>> No, that's not. And that's the point.
The point is is that according to the
Quran, nothing is added to these books.
Nothing is nothing is they're not
corrupted. What is with them in the
Torah and Gospel, the Torah and the
Gospel that they have with them are
true. Period.
>> Right? what they have with them, the
Torah and the Gospel. So, okay, let me I
think this would be help to have a
visual aid. Hold on a second, man. Okay,
so we're going to do some squiggly lines
and then this this. Okay, I'm going to
try to draw this reverse uh so that if
it mirrors, it works properly. All
right, can you see this what I got going
on here?
>> Yeah, it's inverted, but yeah, I see it.
>> Okay, I'm sorry. But here's basically
the thing. Okay, so this would be the
original things. This would be the
original that with them. the part of
divine beings. So when the prophet comes
to confirm, right, he's confirming what
they have that's actually legitimate. So
when the prophet comes and says for
example 1, two, three, six, right? He's
not saying any four and five. You know
what else they might have with them?
They might have camels. They might have
sandals. They might have so many other
things. That's why the context is
crucial.
>> But hold on. So if I were to say, hey,
that sticky note that you have, that
sticky note that's with you, I'm
confirming it. So, does that include all
six sentences?
>> Well, here's the point that I'm making
though, right? The specific thing that
he says he's confirming, that's what's
with them.
>> Is the stick is the sticky note with
you? Is the sticky note with you?
>> Yeah, I have it right now.
>> Okay. So, if I say I'm confirming the
sticky note with you, that includes
those two corrupted lines on the sticky
note, right?
>> What does the verse say?
>> Confirming what is with them.
>> Confirming what is with them. You know
what else is with me? A cup of soup.
>> It's talking about It's talking about
the scriptures, bro.
>> It's talking about the scriptures.
>> It's talking about what they have,
right? But there's a lot of things that
could be happen.
I need you to I need you to focus here
cuz cuz like we're going to shut this,
you know, cut this short and move on. If
I say that I'm confirming that sticky
note with you, does that include all six
lines on that sticky note?
>> No.
>> If you're confirming the sticky note
with me, if you're saying you're
confirming the sticky note with me, then
it'll be all six lines.
>> Exactly. So unfortunately though with
that statement, I'm confirming even
those two corrupted lines on that sticky
note. Right.
>> It's confirming. But again, I now I feel
like we're going in circles again.
Right.
>> Answer
>> once more. Look, this is where this is
where we have in the Quran, it talks
about it, too. Right.
>> You got to answer, bro. Please.
>> No, because I I am answering you. I told
you when you say I'm confirming that
sticky note, you're saying this to me,
right, in this conversation? Absolutely.
>> So that so that means that that means
that I just confirmed even the two
corrupted lines in that sticky note,
right?
>> The two corrupted lines. But the point
that I'm trying to make here, cuz I
think what you're trying to do is you're
trying to isolate a specific portion and
utilize it for the argument.
>> I'm not right. So if we said we All
right. All right. We said we're going to
be fair. So let me just make a point
real quick. Okay. Again, in this verse,
>> if you can deal with this, please cuz
this is in this is crucial, dude. I I
feel like you're not dealing with what
I'm asking you. The sticky note,
>> you're asking me
and believe.
Oh, hold on. Hold on. Believe in what I
have revealed to you, confirming that
which is with you.
>> Confirming
that which is with you. And don't be the
first ones to disbelieve.
What I said
one second. Hold on. I think I might
have finally found a way to break our
loop.
>> Okay. Feel like a life react is just
tired of everything, huh?
>> He's entertained. You good, bro?
>> You need to drink his little coffee.
Keep putting up that circle. All right.
If so, so just a reminder, if I'm saying
that I confirm that sticky note with
you, that means that all six lines that
you showed me, I confirmed. I'm saying
is correct. Even those two
>> those two corrupted lines, number four
and five. So, I will be corrupt I will
be confirming a corrupted sticky note.
Right? I'll be saying a corrupted sticky
note is true. That's the dilemma you're
in.
>> Give me one second. What I'd like to do
is I'd like to read the the because the
verse is, you know, like the full thing
context,
>> right? I want to read the verse after.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Sure. I'm just I'm talking
or you'll just Oh, go ahead.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, children of Israel, remember my
favor is upon you. Fulfill your covenant
and I will fulfill mine and stand in awe
of me alone.
>> What verse?
>> So, this is uh 40.
>> Got it.
>> Same chapter.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So, chapter 40, I mean, sorry,
chapter 2, verse 40.
So, this is this specific thing, right?
It's God talking to uh uh you know the
children of Israel, right? It would be
the Jews, right?
>> So it says, "Oh children of Israel,
remember my favors upon you. Fulfill
your covenant and I will fulfill mine
and stand in awe of me alone. Believe in
my revelations which confirm your
scriptures. Do not be the first to deny
them or trade them for a fleeting gain
and be mindful of me." Right? And then
the next verse right after that, I
really do need to memorize this whole
book. It says, "Do not mix truth with
falsehood or hide the truth knowingly."
And then after that it says establish
prayer pay pay alms tax and bow down
with those who bow down which is
essentially the essential message of
Islam. Right? So that is amazing because
this whole time I was so fixated on
verse 41 42 literally clarifies it. Do
not mix truth with falsehood or hide the
truth knowingly. Now listen. Okay. I
think that
>> Yeah. How does this help?
>> Because it literally addresses the fact
that there are people who come up and
add stuff to the to
>> No. No it doesn't. No wait. Stop. Does
does it say that they mix truth with
falsehood or does it say don't mix truth
with falsehood?
>> If I tell you don't speed, why would I
tell you don't speed?
>> To warn me. My wife tells me all the
time even before I do it.
>> That's fair. But the point that I'm
making is this verse is added. Why would
it be added if it's not something that's
happening?
>> Because it's a warning. It's not that.
It's not that it No, dude. Please.
Simply saying do not mix truth with
falsehood does not mean that falsehood
and truth was mixed into the Torah. He's
telling them don't do it. Or this that
another way that this could is said is
that because you have verses that talk
about how they distort with their
tongues. They misinterpret the
scriptures. So they could be mixing
truth with falsehood orally, not
textually, misinterpreting the book.
They do that with the Quran as well. So
>> So what I would like to do, I think this
would be a fair way to kind of just put
this through. All right. The easiest way
at the end of the day, right?
Ultimately, the only way that we could
actually verify specifically what you're
saying is if we knew what specifically
that they had with them at the time,
>> the Torah.
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold
on, hold on, hold on, hold on. If it was
the entire Torah, then the prophet
himself would have came and recited the
whole Torah to them.
>> No, he would not.
>> He didn't know the whole Torah.
>> He didn't know the whole Torah. So,
whenever he comes and conveys something,
right, if it aligns, it aligns. It's
considered validating. If it's not
something random, bro, this is why I
gave you the sticky note thing. Look.
Okay, hold on.
>> I have to do this.
>> I have to do this now cuz I I I need you
I need you to answer this straight away.
They had the Torah in Muhammad's time.
Correct.
>> Was the Torah available at Muhammad's
time versions of it? Sure.
>> Okay. The Quran confirms the Torah
that's with them according to this
verse. Right.
>> Quran confirms. It says to believe what
is confirmed with them within the
scriptures. It says, "Believe in what I
have revealed, confirming that which is
already with you." So, does the Quran
confirm the Torah with it with them?
>> Dude, it literally says, "Believe in my
revelations." Right. Believe in my
revelations. The Quran which confirms
your scriptures.
>> Exactly.
>> If it says the same thing, it confirms.
If it doesn't say the same thing, it
doesn't confirm. I don't know why it's
so different.
>> So, let's stick with the what the verse
says. According to the verse,
>> does the Quran confirm the Torah that's
with them?
>> We got to do this again. Hold on, man.
And I really want my question soon.
>> You got to be honest here then.
>> I'm gonna be honest.
>> Okay. So, does it say that? Does it say
that he that it
>> I'm going to break it down for you
really really well? I don't I don't
think this is going to happen.
>> Muhammad listen respectfully. I I I have
I've allowed a lot of breakdowns. I've
allowed a lot of explanations. I've been
very patient. I am asking right now a
straightforward question. It doesn't
require breakdown. Please. Does it say
that the Quran is confirming the Torah
they have with them?
>> This is how it's confirmed right here.
That's it. This is confirmation.
>> Does it say it or not, bro?
>> No. No. It's right here. Your answer is
right in front of you, man.
>> All right. So, you're playing games.
>> It makes perfect. No. No. I This is a
very fair way to put it. Okay.
>> Cuz you're asking me to say
>> if if you're playing games, I'm going to
be forced to move on to the next person,
bro. But I don't
>> Oh, come on now, dude. You said you let
me do my question.
>> I will, but you got to be honest with
this. You got to be honest. I'm not I'm
not going to be here playing games. If
you can't be honest, then there there is
nothing for me to know.
>> I asked a straightforward question, bro.
Straightforwardly.
>> All right.
>> According to the text of the verse,
>> does it confirm the Torah that's with
them? Yes or no? Muhammad,
>> believe in my revelations. This is a
revelations, right? Again, obviously
this is an example of revelations.
Believe in my revelations confirming
what you have. So when it's aligned,
it's confirming. Now, does this thing
confirm this thing? No, of course not.
So when it says apple and apple that
it's confirmed. When it says green and
orange that means it's not confirmed. I
think that's a very simple way of
putting it. I don't know why you're
having such like why this is bothering
you so much because you want me to say
oh well this and that but it's not
working. That's isn't how this works.
The confirmations in your way of seeing
it versus the confirmations where it's
being presented are not the same. That's
the presentation I'm trying to show you.
The Quran is confirming. This is how
it's confirmed. My revelations, not my
prophet, not what I'm saying. Go ahead
and watch this clip back, man. Go ahead
and just watch this clip right back and
think and when you watch this back,
think, man, was I honest with his
question. You know, he he was we were
having a a awesome conversation the
whole time. He allowed me to speak. He
allowed me to break down my my what I
thought in my explanations. Why? Why
this time was I dropped? Is it because I
wasn't being honest this time? I wasn't
really answering his question. I was
dodging. Was was what I was doing in the
last 5 minutes different from how I was
engaging the first 45?
>> Islam, man. That's
>> Notice how difficult this is. You guys
hate your book, bro. Y'all hate the
Quran. Just say it. Just come here and
just finally say it. We hate the Quran.
Say it. Whatever the Quran says, you are
determined to say the opposite. Whatever
the Quran says, you're determined to add
words to it or take away from it
>> because it doesn't match what you
believe and what you think. Just say it.
We could we could respect, right, life,
if a Muslim came up and say, "Hey man,
I'm a Muslim. I'm going to be real with
y'all. I hate the Quran. Whatever Allah
says, I'm going to try to make it fit
what I believe." We would respect that,
wouldn't we?
>> Right. For sure. Because that's what
they do. Just be at least be honest with
Yeah, I see what it say. But, you know,
Yeah. Let me go ahead and do Yeah,
that's what that that's that's what they
do. I mean, we can give as as y'all saw,
we gave him ample amount of time. Even
even with my build, it was it was it was
like pulling tooth to nail, you know?
It's like, bro, what are we doing? You
know, but when you give someone like
that who's nice, you know, you give them
that time cuz I've even done it before,
too. cuz it's it's a it's it's
refreshing to deal with someone like
that, but then it gets annoying when
it's like, "Oh, okay. You're just the
same type of Muslim with just a nicer
tone." And it's annoying, bro. Like,
it's annoying. Like, Logic walked him
down every single aisle he wanted to go
down in order that where he was trying
to go to try to justify his Quran. And
every single point was literally, it's
so so funny that he pulled it up on his
own notes. Yes. No. Yes. No. Yes. No.
Yes. No. He told on himself in the notes
that y'all y'all didn't see cuz it was
backwards on uh
uh uh Streamyard on YouTube on Tik Tok.
Oh, wait. It was backwards on Tik Tok,
too. On his notes said yes, no, yes, no,
yes, no. That's exactly what he was
doing on stage. Exactly what Islam is.
When you try to ask questions about
their Quran, yes and no. Yes and no. Yes
and no. It's a religion that's not
stable. your Islam is not stable. Simple
as that.